انت شايف الوضع صعب واني بعين اودي من
نفسي لحالي انا واولادي بنعين عينوني
وبيعين ابوهم في نفس الوقت وجوزي في
مستشفى نصر موجوده الحين هم اولادي
بشتغلوا عملوا بليله بشتغلوا اثنين صغار
واحد صف رابع واححد صف خامس ووضعه صعب
جوزي يعني من يوم ما دخل مستشفى ناصر لحتى
اليوم وهو عمليات كل عملياته عمليات
بلاتين في رجلين
كل يوم بزوره كل يوم بروح على جوزي من
اللي بيعملوه اولادي يعني باخذ منهم يعني
اللي بطلعو اللي بفروه من شغل اودي بروح
في على جوزي باخذ اللي يلزمني وبودي لله
اياه انا مرا بكون عندي اكل ولا شرب يعني
بعص عليهم بقول لهم فيش يا ماما اليوم اكل
خلص علبه الفول بسبع شيكل اجيب علبه الفول
لسبع افراد هم ست وانا سبعه تكفي مين
وتكفي مين علبه الفول لما بدي
اجيبها
لما كان ابوي هان قبل ما يروح لما كان ه
كان يسلينا وكان يلاعبنا يضحكنا وكنا ننسى
انه في حر كنا يعني نلعب مع بعض ونمزح كنا
نكيف بس لما الحين راح ابويا هي فيش مع
اخوان بطلنا نمزح و نتكلم مع
بعض الحين ثلاث اسابيع اللي فاقده جوزي ما
بشوف اولاده بجوا في بقولي يا ماما بدنا
ابونا بسكتو
طب انا الحين انا المسؤوليه كلها على راسي
انا اربع اولاد والاكل والشرب واله كله
عليا يعني من كتر الزن زن زن على راسي مش
قادر اتحمل انا انا بروح بش بصرت اسيبهم
واشرد على المستشفى لان افرق طاقه في
الليل كلهم بيناموا انا دمعت بضل على خد
في الليل ما بتحملش جوزي هذا ماه ما كان
بضل
جوزي اولادي يصحبوا علي في اللي بطلنا حسس
عليهم وبطلنا صحي غير
بفكر في اللي جاي ما بفكرش جاي اصعب من
اللي راح انا بدبر طحين يوم ما فيش عندي
طعين من وين اطعمهم ل ما كان يجين من هنا
ومن هنا ومين يعني عايشه على
الصدقه يعني الناس فعلين الخير بدوني كان
ضعت بين
الرجلين اه انا جوزي ضل بالشمال وما بعرفش
عنه اي حاجه واحنا حاليا هينا عايش شيلت
اربعه ولايا لحالنا
اي حياه صعبه صعبه صعبه
علينا يعني ما عننا ولا زلبه ولا شيء
صعب مدبرين حالنا هنا في اهل الخير
بيطبخوا
بجيبو بتروح بنتي بتجيب
بالطنجره الطحين ما عندنا اي حاجه ما عننا
حتى رحت اسجل امبارح عند المختار للطحين
قاللي خ وقفوا التسجيل بنتي مع اربعه
تنفار وهديك نفرين وانا نفرين وهذه اختي
معها اربع تنفار
الثانيه
صعب انا وحيده باولادي جوزي بغزه بعرف شي
عنه الاتصال انقطع عني عنهم ولحتى الان ما
بعرف اشي عنهم يعني وانا الاولادي عايشين
بدون اب هان مسؤوليتهم انا حلاها يعني ه
ممكن الانسان يدبر حاله من حدا من اللي
حوالينا اما بالنسبه لدخل او بمبد ما في
يعني عندي الاولاد محتاج بمب
شغله كان
يعني كانان البيت وثان الاولاد انه يجيب
له كل شي
فراح